we have a lot of show and I'm just
noticing right now this is straight
never do this but I left my notes
backstage can someone bring out my notes
please for the show oh great thank you
very much thank you Stanley
you're welcome Conan Oh
can I say something yeah sure whatever
what is it this is probably gonna make
me sound paranoid but I think that
Stanley wants my job
you think Stanley our stagehand wants
your job yes you're right that is
paranoid Stanley Stanley get out here
please can you back out of here please
welcome our real Conan O'Brien
okay Stanley Andy thinks you want his
job that's ridiculous
see any but not as ridiculous as the
quality of tonight's guests Jesse Tyler
Ferguson
[Music]
[Applause]
a musical guest Chrissie ha
you're not helping come on don't you see
what he's doing
and he's just making some casual
conversation that's right just some
casual conversation with my boss Conan
you'll never be the announcer Stanley
What's Wrong Andy there's no reason for
you to get so defensive I'm not being
defensive you jackass I'm just showing
Conan who the real pro is oh when you
say Conan are you talking about Conan
[Applause]
no I'm talking about Conan
[Music]
both of you both of you shut up
sorry sorry about that mr. O'Brien -
what happened again
stick around lays down the move stick
around ladies general take a break we'll
be right back with Jesse
you